mike bravo coach of the titans that team
was two and four after six games
remember they had beaten the browns
stunned the browns week one went one and
four after that they've turned it around
the benching of marcus moyota for ryan
tannehill really one of the big factors
in that reversal of fortune for the
titans it's pft live friday edition
conference championship weekend is upon
us we've talked a lot about the 49ers
and the packers that's the late game on
sunday guys let's focus some more on the
titans and the chiefs and specifically
the titans and the specific angle i want
to take here because it's been all about
derek henry and if they win on sunday
it'll be the first time since 2005 that
the russian champion is in the super
bowl remember back in august or so when
jerry jones said you don't need to have
the rushing leader to get to the super
bowl well if the titans get there it's
because they had the rushing leader but
let's say the chiefs take away derrick
henry can ryan tannehill the top 10 pick
from 2012 who was finally run out of
miami and they paid part of his salary
this year to facilitate a trade can ryan
tannehill get it done big cat if derek
henry gets shut down
how are they shutting down derek henry
does the chief set now have 20 guys on
the field like what in what world is
derek henry when you say shut down give
me the numbers give me the stat line of
a shut down derrick henry because i
don't seem like
they said it this year well what yeah
what is it no but what is it 100 yards i
mean 90. i mean i think it's a valid
question i said this yesterday yeah what
is shutting let me listen let's do it a
different way let's do a different way
because i think the more likely reality
is the chiefs open up the kind of a lead
that forces the titans away from the run
that that's the derrick henry's still
getting his yards but they're down 17
points in the third quarter and the only
way they're getting back in this game is
if ryan tannehill can light them up do
you think he can
i don't know i i would say no but here's
my other part of this question is derek
henry has been so explosive and been
able to rip off such huge runs and five
yards of carry and boom now he's gone
for 70. i don't think the titans
drastically have to change their offense
even down 14 in the third quarter i
think if derek henry can get yards
that's still your best play and hope
that you can play some defense against
the chief's explosive offense so yes
ryan tangel probably can't do it all on
his own but i don't think they're going
to ask him to do it all on his own and
if there as long as derrick henry is
getting yards and those are positive
plays they can kind of stick with that
and hope that things you know they get a
turnover or something happens where they
can uh you know flip the script and and
the the titans what they have done mike
they've been at historic level right now
with red zone offense and finishing
drives and if they're able to keep that
they'll be in this game because that's
what they do they don't kick field goals
they literally do not kick field goals
they get seven points when they're
driving the football so
they'll be able to stay in the game
if they can just keep that historic run
which you might say hey that's probably
not going to keep up because it is
historic going and ryan tannehill is
never going to be asked to do too much
so i guess the answer to your question
is no i don't think ryan tano can do it
all himself but i also don't think he's
going to be asked to do it all himself
no i mean i think there's a lot of
reality to that well i mean you know
first off i think
yeah you're right big cat they're gonna
stay patient with the run until maybe if
they get down by 21 or more then they
got to abandon it but i think it's a
real question i mean you know really yes
kansas city's run defense is good what
is stopping derek henry what is it is it
just keeping to a hundred that's what i
kind of argue right now like he's gonna
get a hundred you just don't want him to
get to 180 and 190 like we've seen over
the last few weeks that's when you know
you're in trouble you know i think you
can deal with hey let's talk about the
saints in the houston texans towards the
end of the year when they went into
tennessee they held derrick henry to
like 90-something yards that's a win
24 carries 90 yards can kansas city do
that i don't know they've shown to be
really awesome and run defense towards
the end of the year you know they got a
lot of big people as we know but this
tannehill thing is crazy first off i
mean it reminds me almost of like trent
dilfer in 2000 with the ravens right he
just has to make like a few throws every
game but you know
i think the stats are a little skewed a
little bit where the titans just do what
they got to do to win and he's had
important throws in both games i mean
hey the touchdown pass against the the
patriots the little post route to ferc
sir down the middle of course last week
two touchdown passes both very
aggressive
i do think if they have to rely on
tannehill throwing the ball that they
can move the ball that way especially
with khalif raymond back in the lineup
number 14 when they have him and aj
brown and corey robinson all on the
field that's when it becomes a pretty
dangerous group and khalif raymond beat
him deep we saw it last week against the
ravens he did it against the chiefs so i
do think tanner hill showed me enough
that you know again i don't think he's
gonna throw up for 400 yards or
something like that but he can move the
ball down the field when he has to and
they're put in that corner as a football
team
it's amazing when you look at his
performance so far in the post season
eight for 15 against the patriots crazy
for 72 yards seven for 14 against the
ravens for 88 yards
i mean that that's that's like a half
of a normal game two full games for for
ryan tanner
and quarter
it's amazing it's amazing when you
compare the two
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports